[Musique]
bonjour chantal maignan un jour à la
libre et vous êtes présidente du parti
régionaliste martiniquais candidate aux
législatives dans le centre l'atlantique
pour la république en marche c'est bien
ça c'est exact le gouvernement n'est pas
encore connu le fait que cela prenne un
peu de temps est ce que cela montre ne
montre pas la difficulté ou les limites
de l'exercice d'être à la fois de droite
et de gauche
je ne crois pas je crois tout simplement
que c'est un acte de responsabilité et
il faut bien que le premier ministre qui
vient d'être nommé délit fuit
l'engagement sur l'honneur de chaque
chacune des personnalités qui va
accepter d'entrer dans ce gouvernement
parce qu'il ne s'agit plus de faire de
la politique à gauche ou à droite
il faut véritablement s'inscrit dans le
projet de la pratique politique nouvelle
impulsée par emmanuel macron et c'est
toute la difficulté que connaissent les
français nous qu'en martinique
on sait ce que signifie être
progressiste mais pour les français
c'est un exercice qui est tout nouveau
emmanuel macron effectivement à
transgresser tous là mais je n'ai pas
seulement des mots ce ne sont pas
seulement des mots c'est véritablement
une pratique politique qui doit changer
c'est à dire apprendre à la fois
apprendre ce qui bien à gauche à prendre
ce qui est bien à droite et à créer
quelque chose de nouveau pour ce n'est
pas un assemblage hétéroclite ur
artificiel oui mais est-ce que ce n'est
pas un jus de déquilibre permanent je ne
crois pas je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui a très vite compris qu'il fallait
transgresser qu'il fallait aller très
vite et très loin anticipées si nous
voulons survivre
la france est aujourd'hui une nation
déclinante il faut la remettre
effectivement parmi dans le concert des
premières nations du monde je crois que
l'investiture a montré qu'il avait
compris l'intérêt et l'importance de
restaurer l'autorité de l'état et il
attend de ses ministres aussi cet
engagement cette compréhension cette
vision partagée et je crois que tous
ceux qui vont signer qui vont accepter
effectivement de faire partie de ce
gouvernement auront compris qu'il va
falloir cesser d'être de droite c'est
d'être de gauche pour devenir
véritablement un progressiste c'est à
dire travailler à la restauration de la
france vous savez s'il y aura des
représentants d outre-mer au
gouvernement
on a parlé beaucoup de darwish à l'us le
président de la région guadeloupe
je crois qu'il faut sortir des attentes
classique et traditionnelle je pense
qu'il y aura des ultramarins dans tous
les ministères
parce que l'idée n'est plus de
reconduire comme à l'ancienne miss
finistère des outre-mer avec un petit
budget dédié mais véritablement et même
si ce mini c'est conserver puisque je ne
suis pas dans le secret des dieux comme
vous l'avez constaté emmanuel macron
quelqu'un de très secret et qui demande
à chacun de conserver cette ce respect
spa et c'est lui le premier ministre qui
doit annoncer les choses dont je vais
pas commencer deux mois par transgresser
cette consigne mais ce quelques nouveaux
skis très intéressant c'est qu'il y aura
désormais des ultramarins dans tous les
ministères
autrement dit lorsque le budget par
exemple de la fonction publique où le
budget des collectivités le budget des
entreprises sera déterminé il y aura des
experts ultramarins qui vont parler de
la situation économique des différents
territoires
donc on ne sera plus à pas on n'aura
plus le traitement à part on sera plus
là juste pour faire des petites
manifestations n'est ce pas sur l'autre
mais avec un budget riquiqui
mais les outre mer seront véritablement
intégrée à la gestion de l'anoci sont
remis en cause l'existence même de nous
des hommes c'est une question que l'on
peut se poser tout à fait et elle est
pertinente mais ça permet aussi de ne
plus être à part je sais que les
antillais sont très attachés à au
ministère d outre-mer mais en même temps
est-ce qu'on ne reste pas dans une
espèce de regard un peu coloniale dans
une pratique un peu sienne je crois
qu'il faut véritablement exigé d'être
présent dans tous les ministères à tous
les endroits où se prennent des
décisions avec des budgets conséquents
est ce que le choix du douar philippe
pour vous de joie judicieux excellent
choix excellent choix l'homme d'abord
correspond vraiment on va dire allah a
la stature macron c'est un homme discret
c'est un homme extrêmement compétent
c'est un homme d'une grande
bienveillance qui a énormément de
respect dans les changes qu'il a avec
les personnalités sera capable de parler
avec les syndicats de parler avec les
chefs d'entreprises mais tout en restant
très projets peuvent vous voyez d'où il
vient c'est aux maires de petites villes
avec des difficultés rural lui-même ils
viennent de milieux modestes
donc c'est un excellent choix il
correspond véritablement à l'esprit
progressiste prenez par emmanuel macron
parlons maintenant des législatives et
donc de vous expliquez moi comment on
passe de l'ump du prm puis de plm pour
ensuite atterrir à en marche à la
république en manche
alors je vous remercie de poser cette
question je vous remercie vraiment parce
qu'elle me permet de clarifier un
certain nombre de choses et c'est
tellement logique lorsque je suis rentré
à l'ump en 2007 j'étais effectivement
très intéressé par ce nicolas sarkozy de
2007 qui vous vous en foutez souvenez
avec annoncé l'ouverture jusqu'à gauche
au point d'être taclé par devedjian qui
lui avait dit qu'il fallait peut-être
que l ouverture jusqu'à la droite et ses
propos amis donc c'était déjà une
tentative d'essayer de transgresser mais
qu'il n'a pas mené à bien
parce que c'est laid c'est vraiment très
vite enfermé dans la ligne buisson c'est
à dire une espèce de radicalisation sur
la droite avec ce discours de dakar qui
a été épouvantable et qui a fait que
j'ai pris une décision
c'est celle de quitter l'ump et de créer
le parti régionaliste martiniquais et
déjà la charge de ce parti local ce
petit parti local c'était et le droite
et de gauche
puis nous avons tenté l'aventuré c'était
logique 2e pmn parce que pme n'est pas
un parti politique et donc par
conséquent un peu mais elle n'a pas par
exemple à donner des instituts c'est pas
un parti politique c'était un projet
global avec et la droite et la gauche
le l'échec 2e pme n'a été de ne pas
donner à la loi toute la responsabilité
c'est à dire qu'on était venu mais comme
une espèce d'appoint on est venu pour
faire quelque chose d vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé en face à eux ils ont
fait effectivement la même chose ils ont
fait également une alliance de gestion
mais en donnant à la droite des postes à
responsabilité on le voit aujourd'hui a
quand même des gens qui ont été placés à
des responsabilités de gestion comme ils
ont réussi donc aujourd'hui c'est tout
naturellement que le parti régionaliste
martiniquais se retrouve dans ce nouveau
parti national on l'attendait on
l'espérait nous étions parties locales
parce que nous n'avions pas en face de
nous le parti national qui prônait ce
rassemblement de valeurs de droite et
des valeurs de gauche mais pas seulement
de manière artificielle 1 dans une
pratique nouvelle de la politique et de
la gestion du pays vous vous adversaires
disent de vous que vous êtes une
opportuniste une opportuniste c'est un
compliment quand on est en politique ça
vous dit qu'on a eu on a la vision de ce
qui convient de faire au bon moment ceux
qui restent sur le bord du chemin par
exemple comme aujourd'hui ceux qui n'ont
pas compris que emmanuel ma couette un
progressiste qui est vraiment dans
l'esprit de ce que nous souhaitions
créer en martinique
eh ben ça veut dire que c'est dommage
pour eux mais c'est pas dit qu'ils n'ont
pas de sens politique
l'opportunité d'une forme d'intelligence
quand elle n'est pas mise au service de
l'intérêt personnel
donc vous savez c'est quelque chose qui
ne peut me déplaire je crois tout
simplement que je suis quelqu'un de très
réactif j'ai observé emmanuel mâcon
depuis deux ans parce que j'avais été
attiré mon attention a été attirée par
quelqu'un qui le connaît bien et qui
m'avait dit il faut que tu t'intéresses
à cette personne parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui se démarque véritablement
des anciennes pratiques politiques et
c'est vrai que je n'ai suivi j'ai
regardé avec intérêt la démission du
gouvernement
la démission de son de son poste était
associé à la banque
il a tout abandonné pour cette aventure
sans vie ne suffit pas tout simplement
sur la vague mâcon non peuvent à surfer
sur une vague quand vous le connaîtrez
mieux parce que c'est qu'à mener connu
encore pour le grand public vous verrez
que c'est quelqu'un qui a de vraies
convictions vrai projet de développement
une vraie responsabilité
ce qui m'a beaucoup plu c'est qu'il nous
met en face de nos responsabilités faut
pas croire qu'on ira dans des
gouvernements et qu'on fera rien il y
aura chaque année une évaluation de
l'acte politique de la pratique
politique et on vous serez remercier si
vous ne faites rien je crois que jamais
je n'ai entendu tel appel à la
responsabilité y compris sur le plan
local
quand on me dit quel est le programme
des manuels mâcon pour les outremers j
attendais mais il n'a pas fait de
programmes pour nous il nous a donné les
grandes lignes
parce qu'il a des idées pour le
développement de l'outre-mer mais il
nous appartient à nous on fonctionne
d'autres territoires respectifs de venir
nourrir ce projet prend votre mère alors
samedi vous avez participé samedi
dernier à la réunion des candidats
investis par en marche au mieux au musée
du quai branly à paris ont été les
consignes vous êtes revenu avec un kit
lrm pour mener campagne
nous sommes revenus surtout avec une
puissante motivation parce que le
président s'investit vraiment et
s'investit dans la campagne
à côté de ces candidats on parle
beaucoup de candidats novice je crois
qu'on a tort nous venons tous à part les
énarques nous venons tous de la société
civile de man avant notre politique
j'étais professeur à l'université donc
c'est tout appris par la politique et
sur le terrain y a pas de meilleur
endroit pour la politique que le terrain
donc il a surtout recommandé à tous les
candidats d'être vraiment sur le terrain
de comptes de connaître les les
administrés et d'écouter d'être
bienveillant d'être respectueux et donc
nous avons pris un engagement sur
l'honneur de faire une campagne de
respect de bienveillance parce que c'est
ainsi qu'il entend dans la pratique
politique
il n'a donc pas nous intéresser attaquer
nous nos adversaires et en corse son
adversaire s'allier les autres personnes
qui viennent propose un pour justement
simplement nous entrons politique en dit
nous nous avons pris l'engagement sur
l'honneur de donner au président une
majorité présidentielle et de l'aider
donc à mener à bien la mission qui l'a
proposée aux france vous allez vous avez
un peu répondu à ma prochaine question
13 candidats déclarés pour l'instant sur
la circonscription centre l'atlantique
ça fait un peu beaucoup comment vous
démarquer comment c'est très simple je
dis que emmanuel macron à travers les
candidatures étaient extrêmement observé
un et donc on vous appelle en demande on
regarde votre cv on regarde d'où vous
venez on garde vos compétences et
hangars votre projet moi je le dis très
clairement j'ai et j'assume mais
j'assume totalement moi je me présente
sous cette étiquette de majorité
présidentielle je ferai partie de la
majorité présidentielle si je suis élu
c'est martinique et me donne cette
responsabilité je ne veux pas
m'installer dans une opposition qui
serait une position négative pour notre
pays il est temps que la martinique
participent aux différents ministères
soit à l'elysée soit à matignon pendant
très longtemps nous nous sommes tenus
loin de la pratique politique nationale
ce temps est terminé il faut absolument
aujourd'hui que nous soyons là ça se
décide et que nous fassions tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour que le pays puisse
se redresser quand je dis le pays c'est
mon petit pays la martinique
il y aura la création d'une fédération
de la république manche en martinique
vous serez un parti plp le prm
un parti associé ou bien c'est fini avec
le prm maintenant si la république
marche alors c'est la décision que nous
allons prendre ensemble moi je suis une
présidente je ne suis pas une autorité
qui décide de tout chez nous c'est
vraiment très consensuel donc je reviens
avec des propositions je vais donc
réunir le prm pour leur expliquer un
petit peu le projet de la république en
marche mais il est envisagé de faire de
finir avec l'oeuf et ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas inenvisageable mais simplement
nous devons respecter le collectif de la
société civile qui a énormément
travaillé
nous ne venons pas comme des politiques
nous imposer à la société civile
nous serons humblement à côté d'eux des
premiers marcheurs et qui ont vraiment
qu'ils ont quittée premier marché vous
parlez de match gamma daniel daniel
robes et ensuite parce qu'il ya une très
vieille la cgil et juge que j'allais
beaucoup regretter parce que toute cette
confusion n'est pas à l'image d'emmanuel
mâcon qui lui est un rassembleur
bienveillant donc il est temps de mettre
de mettre de l'ordre dans la maison de
rassembler tout le monde et de faire
véritablement une fédération autonome et
nous tenons à l'autonomie et bien sûr
parce que nous ne sommes pas des
exécutants mais nous allons
effectivement créé cette fédération
avec tout le monde et dans le respect de
tout le monde sait ce que vous allez
travailler avec convergence progressiste
de fred lordinot daniel chomet il est
coupé mais je n'en sais rien ils
viennent de créer quelque chose à vous
dire qu'ils n'ont pas tellement envie
d'entrer dans une logique de en marche
même si pour l'instant ils disent qu'ils
sont des marcheurs je pense que s'ils
l'étaient vraiment il n'aurait pas créé
ce mouvement puisque précisément on va
vers la fin de la balkanisation des
petits partis locaux pour entrer dans
une grande logique nationale donc
j'avoue que la démarche un peu original
et je la comprends pas beaucoup mais on
est fermé à rien chantal maignan je vous
remercie passé une excellente journée à
l'écouté de nos programmes
c'est moi qui vous remercie et je dis
bonjour à tous les martiniquais qui vont
voter j'en suis sûr pour donner une
majorité à notre nouveau président merci
chantal millions
[Musique]
les greta